those comments coming from those
far-right trump-like Republicans who are
continuing to try to distort the reality
so he opened it up Sanctuary City it's
been a sanctuary City will be a
sanctuary City nobody's illegal well
here he is now that uh they're having
some problems because Critics on the
right have noted that New York City is a
sanctuary City and this migrant crisis
comes with that territory what do you
say to those who think uh you relinquish
your right to complain about the
stresses it places on your city because
of that
well I I think that those comments
coming from those far-right trump-like
Republicans who are continuing to try to
distort the reality that we do not have
real immigration reform that we should
allow a true decompression strategy or
protect our borders in the right way and
make sure that when you look at this
city the status of right to shelter of
no one who created this decades ago took
into account that we were talking about
hundreds of thousands of people
potentially coming to coming to the city
guys nobody who thought of this stuff
thought people might actually show up
how was I supposed to know if we said
we're a sanctuary City come here we
won't kick you out we'll give you all
the services and everything else we have
a zillion of examples uh zillion
examples of this across Europe that are
countries like Germany that have
problems now because they let in
millions of people and now their social
services are collapsing how would we
know if you said to people show up we'll
give you Dental Care we'll put you in a
department and all that stuff that
people might take us seriously
how does it really of course it's the
mean Trump Mega Republicans and the
people not taking care of the Border
except I think
um is it a Democrat or a Republican
president right now Democrat President
right it's his guy it's the elderly guy
right